planetenkonstellation bolt sonne um im
zentrum unseres sonnensystems befindet
sich klar die sonne und forscher haben
sich mit dem zyklus der sonne
beschäftigt und dabei erstaunliches
herausgefunden nämlich dass die planeten
die ihre bahnen um den stern ziehen
dabei eine entscheidende rolle spielen
jetzt in klicks um science-fiction
aber schauen wir uns erst mal ein paar
fakten zu unserem zentralgestirn an die
sonne ist ein zwerg stern und ist damit
das was die meisten sterne sind die
haupt reihen sterne zeichnen sich
dadurch aus dass sie in ihrem inneren
wasserstoff fusionieren die sonne
strahlt so schon seit 4,6 milliarden
jahren berechnungen zufolge wird sie
noch weitere fünf milliarden jahre so
aktiv sein es ist also was halbzeit
danach wird die sonne nach einigen
kleineren veränderungen zb erhöhte
leuchtkraft zu einem roten riesen werden
und damit auch die erde vernichten die
sonne hat die 330.000 fache masse der
erde von der sie rund 150 millionen
kilometer entfernten sie steht auch
nicht still sondern sie dreht sich in
ungefähr 28 tagen einmal um sich selbst
allerdings dreht sie sich an ihrem
äquator schneller als an den polen was
daran liegt dass sie aus glas besteht
das licht der sonne benötigt so rund
acht minuten bis es unser reich auf der
oberfläche herrschen rund 5600 grad
celsius im inneren dagegen 15 millionen
grad celsius auf der oberfläche können
kühlere stellen beobachtet werden die
als sonnenflecken bezeichnet werden die
temperatur dort ist rund 1200 grad
celsius niedriger die größe dieser
flecken weist auf die aktivität der
sonne hin
im schnitt steigt die anzahl dieser
sonnenflecken alle elf jahre an wo wir
beim sonnenzyklus wären der sogenannte
schwabe zyklus bisher war nicht ganz
gelöst warum diese periode zieht zur
eintritt im inneren der sonne gibt es
plasma ströme die zwei derartige
prozesse auslösen und so auch für das
magnetfeld der sonne verantwortlich sein
sollen der omega effekt beschreibt das
zirkulierende platz im inneren der sonne
das auch leitfähig ist es entsteht ein
zwei ringförmiges magnetfeld das den
alpha effekt beschreibt diese theorie
über den alfa omega dünger erklärte
bisher aber nicht weshalb der
sonnenzyklus so chaotisch abläuft
forscher vom helmholtz-zentrum
dresden-rossendorf haben sich jetzt mit
der bereits bekannten tatsache
beschäftigt
sich die sonne alle 11,07 jahre mit der
erde der venus und jupiter in einer
linie befindet bisher konnte die
wissenschaft keinen einfluss der
planeten nachweisen das hat sich jetzt
mit einer neuen theorie geändert der
einfluss der schwerkraft der planeten
ist zwar gering könnte aber dennoch
ausreichend seien die aktivitäten der
sonne maßgeblich zu beeinflussen der
alpha dynamo soll den forschern nach
leichter zu manipulieren sein als bisher
angenommen zitat unsere berechnungen
zeigen dass planetare gezeitenkräfte
dabei wie winzige taktgeber von außen
wirken so der wissenschaftler frank
stefanie wirken die kräfte auf das
plasma der sonne kommt es zur taylor
instabilität wenn genügend strom durch
das leitfähige plasma fließt dann
entsteht durch das auftretende
magnetfeld wieder eine neue strömung die
geringe einflussnahme der planeten
reiche dafür aus stephanie erklärt es so
zitat wenn man einer schaukel immer nur
einen kleinen schubs gibt kommt sie mit
der zeit immer mehr in schwung
das reicht dann aus um den alfa effekt
in schwingungen zu versetzen alle elf
jahre kommt es also so zu einem kleinen
schubs der ausreicht dass sich das
magnetfeld der sonne alle elf jahre um
bolt noch hat die theorie der forscher
nicht alle fragen zum sonnenzyklus
endgültig geklärt allerdings sind die
neuen erkenntnisse den wissenschaftlern
zufolge ein logischer ansatz die
prozesse zu erklären wenn euch das video
gefallen hat dann freue ich mich
natürlich über einen daumen nach oben
und über ein kostenloses abo dafür
jeglichen und zu einem weiteren sehr
spannenden video kommt auch hier über
unser sonnensystem
da geht es da lang was meint ihr findet
ihr die erklärung der wissenschaftler
logisch und könnten relativ schwache
kräfte im all so große auswirkungen
haben schreibt mir eure meinung in den
kommentaren und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran